bear markets it's something we haven't
seen in US stocks and roughly a decade
depending on how you look at it they can
either be a major pain triggering panic
or for those with a strong stomach
lucrative buying opportunities either
way investors are on the hunt for the
next bear you'll spot one when the
market drops twenty percent or more from
its peak predicting the next one can be
really tough even for professionals but
there are some key charts that top
investors have found helpful at
predicting bear markets in the past so
let's take a look at how some of these
fared before the last two bear markets
first up the yield curve when the gap
between long term and short term
government bond yields is climbing like
this it generally means investors think
the economy is healthy and growth will
be stronger in the future but when it
starts to shrink and goes negative like
this that's when you might want to watch
out this is the dreaded inverted yield
curve and it usually means investors are
really scared about the future of the
economy in 2006-2007 it inverted as the
Fed lifted rates to try to cool the
housing market a bear market followed as
well as the worst financial crisis since
the Great Depression since 2014 the
yield curve has been flattening bringing
us once again pretty close to an
inverted curve so is it an ominous sign
no one's really sure there's a heated
debate some analysts say that years of
never before tried monetary policies
like negative interest rates in the
eurozone and Japan have distorted
long-term rates blurring the picture
here's an indicator about investor
sentiment zoomed out like this it kind
of looks like an electrocardiogram but
here's what you need to know when the
charts really high investors are feeling
optimistic and when it's really low
they're feeling pretty bearish let's
have a look at January 2000 the highest
point ever recorded on this survey the
world wide web was all the rage the
Nasdaq was going vertical and investors
would buy pretty much anything with
dot-com in its name I think we all know
how that one turned out this chart is
not always predictive but keep an eye on
the extremes when investors get really
really bullish it can sometimes be a
sign that their expectations are just
too high
and there's not a lot of cash left on
the sidelines to cushion any blows on
the flipside really low levels of
optimism actually have the most
predictive power let's take a look at
March 2009 sentiment on the survey was
at its lowest in years just before the
bear market ended if you bought the
market right at its bottom you'd be
sitting on a roughly three hundred
percent return today another sign of
excess deal activity companies snapping
up other companies just before the
dot-com bubble burst in 2000 you had a
flurry of merger activity including Time
Warner's deal with AOL just before the
financial crisis recession in bear
market deal activity spiked again RBS is
deal to buy ABN AMRO the biggest bank
merger ever marked the top so why do
mergers matter they can signal that
companies have gotten excessively
optimistic or that they actually think
deals are the only way to grow as the
economy slows down
lastly jobless claims major bear markets
usually but don't always coincide with
recessions here in both 2000 and 2007
jobless claims start to climb right at
the beginning of what turned out to be
major bear markets steady rise in claims
can signal that something is starting to
go wrong with the labor market when the
job market slows consumers tend to spend
less hitting profits of course none of
these charts on their own can really
give you a concrete answer as to when
the next bear is going to emerge but
taken together they can give you a
pretty useful indicator about the health
of the market so when do you think the
next bear market is due take our poll on
wsj.com or tweet me at gold Reba